damals war meine damen und herren ihr
seht es bereits mit eingeblendeten ich
habe mir einige produkte gestellt die
von instagram auf instagram von
instagram stars beworben werden
ja da ist einiges zusammengekommen
ich würde sagen ich schnarche lang gaben
ich will das erste produkt das denke ich
auch die meisten leute kennen werden
durch werbung sind dinge wellington
uhren als er hat glaube ich jeder schon
werbung für gemacht
ich auch sind aber auch ehrlich gesagt
ganz kleine uhren meine sind beide
ehrlich gesagt stehen geblieben weil ich
nicht frage so ich trage keine ich trage
total selten nur so wenn ich aufs handy
gucke dann habe ich ja meine mutter
gucke alle drei minuten aufs handy und
er weiß ich immer gespielt ist auf jeden
fall bin ich echt ganz kleine kommen
okay die ist schon hart für mich früher
unfassbar viel getragen
ich finde die wohl richtig geil wenn ich
einfach so richtig simpel sind man sieht
okay es ist so aus wie sondern alte
design aber trotzdem mit zum simplen
titel ich werde das ganze video übrig
als werbung kennzeichnen weil ich
einfach so viele produkte hier zeige ich
bekomme von keinem unternehmen hier gilt
dass sich ihre produkte vorstellen aber
ich will rechtlich auf der sicheren
seite sein und nicht das dann
landesmedienanstalt davon dass sich die
un müssen sollte auf jeden fall ist das
eigentlich ein produkt was glaube ich
jeder schon mal gesehen hat auf
instagram der linken oder bin ich aber
ganz ehrlich finde ich sehr sehr cool
und mag ich vom design und auch was die
auf dem star machen also das produkt
immer rein ich kann nicht viel zu sagen
ist halt eine uhr die stehen geblieben
ist bei mir ein produkt zu machen zwei
etwas was jeder von euch kennen sollte
hab ich gesehen hat jetzt sogar in
england irgendwie den launch gefeiert
oder so zwei es von meiner lieblings
youtube interview bellevue ich zeige
euch mal die englische die lose seite
finde ich auch kraß als ein baby auf
jeden fall muss ich ja ganz ehrlich
daniel
hast du den kreis des ding mit
geschaffen also wieder erkennt jeder in
deutschland und es ist man kann nichts
dagegen sagen so es ist ein gutes
produkt ist es einfach veganer essen wie
sowas nicht vegan sein kann
wahrscheinlich geht es da um
irgendwelche kleinen inhaltsstoffe oder
tierversuche ich weiß es nicht genau
auf jeden fall peile ich das wirklich in
ordnung die sache ist nur ich habe mir
noch nie was riecht schon lässt sich so
eine kerze ist schon krass ich habe mir
tatsächlich noch nie einen wir selbst
riecht auch geil ich meine will am
liebsten sollte es raus packen das ende
des weges tatsächlich dass ich mir doch
eigentlich selbst gekauft aber das haben
wir jetzt selber also irgendwelche
zuschauer zuschauerinnen aus john calder
einfach eigentlichen fantreffen
geschenkt einmal auf haben die dann an
stadt wien uhr und nochmal drauf
geschrieben und hernals rausgefahren bin
ich auf jeden fall ehrlich gesagt auch
ein sehr sehr gutes produkt ich weiß wie
youtube youtube erlitt und zu ihren
songs die drei treffen nicht einmal
denken dass man sich ja heute video
gewinnen den vocal coach darauf reagiert
[Musik]
man kann von der youtube würden dieses
youtube 11 denken was man will mit blue
hat sie auf jeden fall kassel produkt
entwickelt das muss man einfach so sagen
es ist ein diether dehm chance nutzen
jetzt nicht aber ich habe denen bei mir
im letzten boom stehen und bin jetzt
dahin nutzen auf jeden fall die ganze
zeit immer das ist auf jeden fall
produkten war 2 kommen wir nun zu einem
produkt was ich selber wirklich richtig
oft nutzen und zwar sind es noch meine
damen und herren ich zeige euch mal hier
instagram anzeige von denen noch sind
ganz einfach
picasso co ihr seht schon wenn man die
ja die also vergleichbar mit dem was ist
wenn ich passen diese hier gibt es
übrigens ebenso wenig von de besorgt
sind übel sind heftig elastische hat man
kann die komplette aus nichts merke
meinen also dass hier sind diese sorgen
die kann man hier hinten quasi umstand
dass geile an küstendorf schlussantrag
was die hinten in diesem in diesem
socken drin so ein kleines gummi ding
haben
dadurch halten die sich quasi direkt
fest ich weiß es sieht übel weil ich aus
dass ich jetzt hab das ding ist aber das
sind perfekte sneakers ob und welche
seite ist man schockiert wenn man sich
den schuh anzieht dann sieht es trägt
man keine socken trägt das ist halt das
leichte das nie ganz offen also es gibt
die sorge wahrscheinlich auch für 1 euro
irgendwo in einem anderen geschäft aber
die sind auf jeden fall mehr weil sie
halt hinter dieses gummi dran namen habe
ich auch gesehen auf dienstag dann habe
ich mir direkt gestellt dennoch sehr
zufrieden mit also doch wieder
aufgezogen freundet sich hier wieder die
lokal socken an
übrigens nur socken das hier kommt auch
in meinen job beim ersten zwölf also die
socken gibt es schon die erste zeit im
shop kann man sich die ganze zeit kaufen
und diesen rudi wird es unter anderem
beim ersten zwölf geben wenn meine neuen
lounge auf jeden fall gerne vorbei auf
jeden fall haben wir uns bisher an
produkten angeschaut denn je wir haben
uns die snobs angeschaut ist nicht als
auch im wir haben uns von dem des beauty
palace buch schauen angeguckt das heißt
nun kommen wir zu etwas was man auch
essen kann und dafür würde ich sagen mir
meine küche das hier finde ich das
nächste produkt freunde das sind gewürze
von der marke just use of spices habe
ich auch wie instagram werbeformen
gesehen
edle gewürze und ich liebe es doch
eigentlich zu kochen in letzter zeit
christi rob hat mir da so ein bisschen
den anschluss von einander herzlich bei
den bau- und wir haben auch mit fisch
und knoblauch unseren nudeln dass keines
gekocht da denkt man auf jeden fall hey
da kann man auf jeden fall geld kochen
und da habe ich mir gedacht dann stelle
ich mir diese jazz zweifel ist die haben
echt klasse gewürze so ich kenne sonst
so gewinnst du italienische kräuter
gewürze salz pfeffer irgendwie curry und
sogar wir haben allerdings so gewürze
wie hähnchen gewürzt pizza gewöhnt
automobils weiß pasta allrounder kräuter
formel gewöhnt spekulationsgewinne
tropical jorge zweifel einen kaffee kuss
also auf jeden fall ausgefallene gewürze
ja wir das nicht schon nach pommes
riecht also man riecht schon die elektro
für die sachen sind allerdings haben sie
sich spekulatius gewürzt hier noch gar
nicht richtig ausgepackt
es sieht eigentlich erst mal aus wie
trockene scheiße oder das geht ja dass
ich krank nach einer also wirklich ganz
ganz ausgefallen wir gewürze die die
hier haben wie gesagt freue mich werdet
ihr für nichts bezahlen dass ich
irgendwie sagen ich sagen meine ehrliche
meinung allerdings habe ich mich
natürlich auch nur produkte bestellt wo
ich mir selber auch denken kann ich
gebrauchen und die sind auch cool dass
sie auf jeden fall die gewürze von jazz
weißes habe ich auch auf insgesamt
vorgeschlagen bekommen das nächste dass
ich auch vorgeschlagen
das habe ich mir tatsächlich bestellt
weil ich mir gedacht habe die idee ist
krank geil wenn es beispielsweise so
beziehungsweise war es lange zeit so
dass ich praktikum studium alles
irgendwie nebenher hatte und hatte gar
keine zeit dafür essen beziehungsweise
habe ich es einfach vergessen und habe
mir gedacht wenn ich unterwegs war
scheint von hunger und hab mir dann
einfach beim bäcker irgendein brück in
ruhe das ist natürlich keine gute
ernährung ich will nicht sagen dass das
die beste ernährung ist oder so aber was
die leute von tool halt machen ist
einfach einen shake den man trinken kann
und er hat quasi von den nährstoffen und
von den kohlenhydraten et cetera pp eine
komplette mahlzeit ersetzen soll ich hab
das ganze noch nie probiert noch nie
getrunken aber ich habe hier die
geschmacksrichtung wann endet bluten
free bestellt und hier steht genutzten
free the flavor nutrition ihren genommen
in montreal und square dance academy of
european junior denen wir können alles
klar
weniger als bei rein das riecht intensiv
der wandel also ich nehme jetzt mal
einfach zwei fette löffel von diesem
tool ich glaube das würde ein
sonnenschirm löffel auf jeden fall
ersetzen
dann fragt jetzt leitungswasser reid 3
ich möchte überhaupt nicht nach einem
schmeckt einfach so nach nach nuss liga
erde mit wasser also dass hier sind
diese zehn flavour zu obsiegen oft
gestellt habe ich zum beispiel parallel
strawberry cetera pp
ich glaube ich packe da einfach ich guck
mal papa mails kommen sonne richtig
ungesunde mischung eigentlich erst
einmal trinken ja ja ja ja und ich suche
vorher hat halt wirklich nur nach ihm
wie flüssiger er den schlecker oder so
aber das ist auf jeden fall dieses tool
was noch auf instagram angezeigt wurde
ich wollte auf jeden fall mal testen ich
glaube wenn man rufen
rot und weiß der verzweigung ist an und
machen das würde ich mir trotzdem was
beim bäcker vollkommen nun allerdings
meine damen und herren zu den vorletzten
produkte und zwar haben wir gerade oben
über das essen geredet gewürze die sind
jüdische hate was macht man nach dem
essen dann putze die zähne und da habe
ich mir dieses schöne stück bestellt das
ist eine 360° elektrische zahnbürste get
ready for clean aktiv breiter smiles und
es ist das hier das ist eine zahnbürste
die legst du dir nur in den mund
die putzt sich die zähne und das ganze
dauert angeblich zehn sekunden
ich habe euch mal den werbung hier
gerade eigentlich aber was man auch
überall bei instagram sieht ist ja diese
ganzen instagram oddity das bestätigt
jene packen und dann haben die hellere
zähne und dann auch colin mcrae da macht
der vergleich auch werbung
das stimmt richtig gegen malta war so
was muss ich jetzt den mund packen
während unsere zahnbürste hier vorne
aufregt weil der damen und herren also
ich musste mir das ding einfach bestellt
zehn sekunden lang kurz die das
geschafft die zähne das soll reichen
also ich habe immer noch selbst die
zähne putzen danach aber so fürs testen
ist es auf jeden fall ganz interessant
ich will sagen waren direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten produkt zu können und zwar
dass dieser boxermotor da habe ich auch
eine werbung von gesehen hab mir den
bestellt weil ich schon immer mal so
eine kleine rutsche haben sollte man
diese anki kosten roboter gesehen denn
ihr wollt dass ich mal zu diesem abend
wie cosmo ein video mache oder mit den
halt
das passiert wenn man leichter das ist
weil dieser roboter in krass also ist an
die cosmo roboter teil des kurses auch
über 200 euro jetzt laden beide produkte
erst mal auf 2000 jahre später also gut
freuen wir haben hier die anleitung zu
diesem roboter durchlesen ich glaube da
muss einfach noch ein bisschen länger
laden was allerdings schon fertig ist es
unser fan putz gerät haben auf die zähne
putzen
ok ich dachte gerade immer nur es extra
so eine spezielle zahnpasta hierfür
verwenden weil ich kann mir das ding
jetzt nicht einfach so im mund schieben
aber hier steht auch you can use
ordinary to space also normale zu haben
dann kommt man einmal kurz auf den an
schalter und direkt das ganze bad voll
wind weißen teuren kennt sich
verschieden die ist ja auch egal wie
schlecht wir dass wir jetzt auf jeden
fall mein mund das haupthaus aufschwung
heißt warum die sagen dass die zähne
dabei sind wie klimt über alles anders
aus den seen deswegen sind die zähne
weise gar keinen sinn es wird damit
geworben dass man sich zehn sekunden
lange mit dem zähneputzen hatte ich die
fünf sekunden sollen wir machen wichtig
wo der fonds weiter machen sollten wir
lieber selbst bedienen
das muss dinge sogar noch sauber waren
und laden alltag gar keinen sinn also
die zahlen wird haben wir auf jeden fall
die zahl ist damit zu ende geht so wenn
jetzt der raum jetzt ist der roboter
dran das geht gesagt der vorwoche gegen
untergrund dekabank was ist mit dem ich
drück nicht nennen die macht fast ein
ding der fährt ihnen worum es verstehen
das ist okay wächst stetig oktober also
man kann die kleinen roboter anscheinend
auch sport in die kreisliga elf roboter
geht jetzt reise der sich selbst befreit
so liegt so der ich trinke nicht viel
ich konnte gar nichts die cover das
denke ich schon
das ding ist wirklich das was mich am
meisten begeistert hier meine damen und
ich drücke gar nichts also dieser kleine
roboter ist er nämlich auf jeden fall am
meisten begeistert von den ganzen sachen
liebe schlagzeilen obwohl ich alter den
roboter finde ich auf jeden fall mit
wir haben uns die d-junioren angeschaut
wir haben uns diese komische zahnbürste
angeschaut wir haben uns wie du
angeschaut die es nicht schaffen den
kleinen roboter gewürzte schule also
einige sagten auf jeden fall
der ist echt im bett lief das video hier
gefallen hat eine daran dass ein
leichter sollte ich noch mal ernsthaft
produkte bestellen die ihr eventuell in
die kommentare schreiben können ich weiß
nicht was bekommt hier so in eurem
instagram vier ganz auf vorgeschlagene
anzeige wieder von influenza oder von
dem unternehmen selbst schreibt
vergeltung in die kommentare
lastet leicht habe ich das ganz normal
days komplett kraft ich fand es bleibt
mir die kommentare auch ich mir noch mal
so und kleinen roboter bestellen sollte
ist ja mal eine hohe alter viel
verabschieden uns gefällt den pulli hier
gibt es am ersten zwölf gemeinschaft
sehe ich genauso
[Musik]